all right guys
bang bang i've got sergey here thank you
so much for doing this sir
thank you for having me good good to
chat with you again thank you
absolutely uh for those that didn't
listen to the first episode that we did
together maybe give us a quick
um you know two minutes on your
background and what chain link does
sure so i've been building smart
contracts now for over seven years
uh through that time i've built a number
of contracts for large um
financial institutions insurance firms
have worked on my own contracts that
have gotten some adoption and
through that time i've kind of come upon
the oracle problem and the problem of
how do contracts connect
to external systems and that connection
to external systems is quite important
because
smart contracts gain their security from
being separate
from the world of other insecure systems
so smart contracts and blockchains
generally only know about what's inside
of them
and the ability for them to know what's
outside of them is what enables
things like defy and decentralized
insurance and all these use cases that
i've been working on for a number of
years
so basically i've i've started to focus
my time and energy on the body of work
around
oracle's and oracles are the technology
that solve this problem so they allow
you to retain the security of a smart
contract
and its extreme reliability while
connecting it to less secure systems
like data feeds
or you know various other systems that
can control the contract
but guaranteeing that those systems
don't manipulate the contract
so basically the contract can now ingest
data about market events
whether any number of other data points
and that enables new types of contracts
to come into existence
of which defy and decentralized
insurance you know those are the two
most prominent examples but there's
there's many others
got it and so maybe let's just start
with like what is defy and what's
driving the growth of the dfi industry
right now
so the centralized finance right right
now is the taking of
existing financial products and the
placing of them onto a blockchain
infrastructure
and there's categories like lending
protocols and derivatives protocols and
what they seek to do
is in the case of a lending protocol
generate yield but generate yield on
crypto assets and provide that yield
in a transparent kind of counterparty
risk informed and and very reliable way
against crypto assets because that's the
format in which you can get the yield
derivatives markets on on a blockchain
have various benefits in terms of
counterparty risk settlement speeds all
these types of benefits
so what what decentralized finance is
really about is
the re definition of what blockchains
and smart contracts are doing
to include financial products right so
far smart contracts and blockchains have
been predominantly about let's make a
token
and tokenization has been the
predominant focus of of these
technologies
which which is fine because tokenization
generates a lot of value and it brings a
lot of value into the ecosystem that can
then be put into various formats
but but at the end of the day that's not
all that smart contracts and blockchains
do
and what decentralized finances is the
creation of financial products
usually around the crypto asset format
so around tokens like bitcoin or other
tokens
and it generates an ecosystem of
financial products
around the tokens that came out of the
first tokenization boom
but it's it's a very important evolution
because the evolution this time is not
about
the creation of more tokens even though
that might be a side effect of of this
evolution
the evolution now is about blockchains
and smart contracts being used to make
financial products
which provide value regardless of the
token or the collateral or the asset
and and really this is where blockchains
and smart contracts
begin to deliver on the promises that
the global financial system seeks to
deliver on but
because of certain technical limitations
is enable is unable to
got it and so when you think of um kind
of the decentralized
finance industry today how would you
look at the progress that's been made
since the last time we talked
are we you know 20 better 200 percent
better
just how do you kind of think about the
progress
um and then maybe compare it to where
you think we'll eventually get are we
kind of one percent of the the way to
to the final state um 20
just give us some ballparks as to how
you think about that progress
uh i think it's it's a very significant
increase i would say it's a
tripling or a quadrupling at least and
and that's
um even borne out partly by the numbers
and the values secured there i think the
value secured numbers or even a larger
increase than that and i think that
there's basically i would say
maybe three three really important
events that have happened
when one of the events is that you have
highly reliable oracles
so you have an ability for decentralized
financial smart contracts
to gain access to external data and
that's a necessary starting point
for them to build something useful and
the amount of data that's now
on a blockchain like ethereum or others
ha is the largest it's ever been and
with each additional piece of data each
additional price feed
each additional piece of weather data
for insurance products or
or commodities data about the
commodities markets
sees the creation of additional on-chain
marketplaces
around that category of financial
products
and so that that is a that is a big
change
that change is part of um
is also part of something called
composability so what what you're seeing
and
what you what you're seeing now that you
didn't necessarily see before as much
is you're seeing the ability to compose
different d5 protocols
together into more advanced protocols so
what you're seeing now is
uh a very historically significant thing
i think because once
in in in in an analogy
once the web began to have enough
libraries
and enough apis you had developers
compose those libraries and apis
into very advanced um applications
consumer applications b2b applications
all kinds of applications for example
uber uber is a combination of libraries
and various apis to do things like get
the location of the
of the user message them through
something like twilio
and pay a driver right and and so
right now in d5 what you see is d5
protocols building these little building
blocks these little pieces of unchained
code
that are that are you could consider
essentially on chain code libraries
that other protocols then come and use
pieces of
and so now you have a larger and larger
body of work that's open source
and that's being continually improved
instead of everybody making their own
version
which is how you arrive at the type of
libraries and developer resources
that underpinned the the leading
applications and leading killer apps
that make the
web and the mobile revolution happen
right and so there's a very
important historical analog to what's
happening right now there
the the oracles are kind of like the
apis right so you're starting to see
apis and libraries appear in mass
and you're seeing more and more
relatively small development teams
combine those oracles and um and and
other d5 protocols on chain
kind of contracts into more and more and
more advanced financial products
very importantly while maintaining
security right so that's
that's maybe the third thing that's
that's that's really happening
is that you have on-chain financial
products
that are able to return a yield of
anywhere between one to eight percent
and they're able to do that for billions
of dollars in value
and they're able to do that extremely
securely
and they're able to properly secure
billions of dollars in value
while creating transparency and their
and they're able to be built by people
that didn't need to build
every single piece of that product so
they were able to take a piece from that
protocol
that has been running for a year and
they know works well and they were
able to take an oracle and you know plug
that in as a data source
and they know that that oracle has been
working for over a year and it's going
to reliably provide them price data
and so teams of anywhere from three to
ten people
are now able to make financial products
that
can securely re create rates of return
and exposure to various you know
outcomes
from from a secure base of building
blocks
and that has led to more and more usage
but really the usage is at a as
at a fraction of what i think it will be
because if you look at the basic numbers
if we're anywhere between 10 and 15
billion in the d5
um kind of ecosystem depending on the
day
and the amount of value in the crypto
format
that can make its way into d5 is in the
450 billion dollar
range then the percentage of value
that's currently getting
the benefits of d5 is still very very
small
and so that alone a doubling of defy
would mean it would go to you know 30 30
billion which wouldn't be even 10
of all the assets that are in a crypto
format if it triples
then we're at 45 billion and that's only
10 percent
at current prices of what the total
possible assets in the crypt because it
need
that that's the one limitation of d5
really is that it needs to have assets
in the crypto format
in order for that asset to gain the
benefit
of d5 absolutely and obviously the
thesis there would be that over time
that
um kind of 450 billion goes up over a
trillion and larger and larger
one of the things i've seen you talk
about in the past i find very
fascinating
is this belief that bitcoin is part of
d5
and can benefit from d5 explain that or
elaborate a little bit
as to what you mean when you say that
i think bitcoin as as the largest crypto
asset
can benefit from the dfi ecosystem
in its creation of a whole suite of
financial products
that allow people to get additional
benefits from holding bitcoin
right so so bitcoin i think is is very
very attractive because
it's inversely correlated with
things like bad monetary policy which
which there's going to be more and more
attention around
in in the coming months and years
it's viewed by more and more people as a
hedge against inflation
which is set to to occur right
and so both of those factors i think are
extremely important
uh to underpin its its it's usefulness
and adoption
to both the average person as shown by
paypal or somebody like that saying we
want to provide
access to this or through things like
microstrategy buying you know 250
million in bitcoin
so both institutions and individuals
there's a lot of proxies
that say like this is attractive because
of an inflation hedge
and being inversely correlated with bad
monetary policy right
but i think there's a third piece of
this puzzle which is also extremely
attractive that that i think is under
underappreciated and that's the benefit
to generate a rate of return on bitcoin
in a trustless way that doesn't depend
on the global financial system
and doesn't depend on standard
standard practices that might be viewed
as um untrusted
trustworthy or unreliable or might not
even get as good a rate of return as you
would get somewhere else
right so i i think the the third piece
of the puzzle that
d5 really brings is the ability for a
bitcoin
to get a rate of return of anywhere from
one to eight percent
by being just like the bitcoin is
trustlessly owned by you
now you can trustlessly engage
in a financial product with this asset
and what that means is that you you
still have the ability to
control that bitcoin you still have the
ability and and now you have the ability
to know the solvency of the financial
product
the solvency of the financial system
very very explicitly
and it's it's all once again backed by
um
trust minimized computation just like
the movement and existence of bitcoin is
backed by trust minimized computation
right
so i think the benefit is that once
people
are able to see bitcoin
as not only a hedge against inflation
just through mere ownership
and not only as an inversely correlated
asset with bad monetary policy or what
becomes publicly considered to be bad
monetary policy
but also as um an asset that provides a
rate of return
right a yield bit generating asset or an
asset that can be put into some kind of
market where
it can be used as collateral or can be
used to basically generate yield for the
holder
and that that exposure to a set of
financial products is as trustless as
bitcoin itself
or close close to being as trustless
i think that in an environment where
yields are probably set to be pretty low
from the global bond market from you
know various other yield
traditionally yield generating um
environments
the ability for people to have an asset
like bitcoin even if it's volatile
at the level of eight percent or five
percent
if you're getting a yield of five
percent or eight percent
then you're you're you have an asset
that that gives you
much much better yield right and i think
this is what
decentralized financial products in
whatever ecosystem that they come to
exist in
can can can make happen for for bitcoin
and
and i think you see this already being
appreciated by certain holders of
bitcoin
through the over 1 billion dollars that
have already flown into other ecosystems
as a bitcoin right so so if a bitcoin
becomes something called a wrapped
bitcoin
it doesn't doesn't lose any value it
still gets purchased and
the demand for wrapped bitcoins
translates to real demand for real
bitcoins
right and so the the more um
basically the more utility the more
value that either institutions
actually institutions and individuals
get from holding bitcoin as an asset
as generated by the default ecosystem
the more bitcoin adoption will happen
and so i i i think it's it's it's it's
an extremely positive relationship where
bitcoin is informing a lot of people
about trustless computation and and all
these types of guarantees that a crypto
asset should have and has
and it's getting people comfortable with
the ideas that you don't want
a financial institution to control every
aspect of your
relationship with your financial life
you can actually have a trustless
relationship
with with the financial part of your
life so it's educating people about that
and i think it's a very logical leap for
people to then go okay
i have this trustless asset that is
you know a good inflation hedge protects
me against bad monetary policy
and it turns out i can actually
use it to interact with various
trustless financial products
and i get all these additional benefits
from that right
do you think that the kind of wrapped
bitcoin um
and the interoperability or
usage in the decentralized finance world
uh
is that in competition with uh kind of
the same
products or same types of mechanisms
being built in a decentralized way
on top of bitcoin like is that an either
or scenario
so either we take bitcoin we wrap it and
we put it into this decentralized
finance
uh kind of ecosystem being built uh or
we build decentralized infrastructure
on bitcoin as kind of another option
are those two things competing or do you
think actually there's a world where
those two things could like live in
coexistence and both happen
i think both can happen i think there's
smart contract platforms like block
stack and rsk that focus on relying on
the security of
bitcoin as the underpinning of of their
of their systems guarantees
i i think generally speaking the bitcoin
blockchain
has been resistant to including a lot of
transactions
that aren't about bitcoin right that
aren't about the movement of bitcoin and
the security of bitcoin
and the perpetuation of bitcoin as a
kind of digital gold alternative
that has all these properties of being
an inflation hedge and being adversely
correlated
with bad monetary policy right and and
so i think that
it it i don't think it i don't think it
actually really matters that much for
bitcoin's success
what environment it happens in i think
the important thing is that it happens
so whether it happens in in an
environment
that is very positive towards bitcoin
or if it's an environment that pushes
more transactions into bitcoin
i don't think that's what what's the
deciding factors for
deciding factor for bitcoin's success
right like at the start of the bit
bitcoin's life and at the start of when
people were really looking at it they
were looking at it for micro
transactions
and they were looking at it for a number
of different things right
and now it's kind of evolved into this
globally known and and increasingly
attractive
inflation hedge and inversely correlated
asset for bad monetary policy like
that's what that's what i consistently
hear now from pretty much everybody
right and and that's fine that's a very
good position
for for that for that asset to be in and
if other people build
systems that are underpinned by bitcoin
security or not underpinned by bitcoin
security
i think people might have a decision to
make about like do i trust the security
of the system where the financial
product is operating
and am i comfortable with the security
guarantees of that system
and therefore am i comfortable putting
my bitcoin into that system
right and do i want to risk um do i do i
want to take the technology risk of that
system
against my bitcoin right and they might
say i want to put that into
systems that are secured by the
by the hash power of the bitcoin chain
and that might make those systems and
therefore the hash power of the bitcoin
chain
more valuable and more useful in certain
ways that's that's entirely possible
but i think that that is um
probably a secondary consideration for
for bitcoin i i think the main
consideration for bitcoin right now is
how does it become um the first
globally recognized government-less
decentralized kind of asset
that is inversely correlated with with
things about the modern financial system
inflation existing ideas about monetary
policy right
and that being accelerated because
there's a yield
coming from some environment somewhere
and that that yield meets this meets
a version of the conditions that bitcoin
seeks to meet
is is is already a very positive step in
the right direction
i i don't think that whether bitcoin
becomes a platform to
to actually house these financial
products is
is particularly critical to success i
don't think that's something that's uh
it's it's sought out
immensely over the years i think part of
the success of bitcoin is because of its
extreme focus
right and and that focus continues to be
you know hedge against inflation
inversely correlated with bad monetary
policy and basically private
private key controlled digital asset
that um
that nobody can take from me because
there's no institution between me and my
asset yeah
what's so interesting about this is
obviously the decentralized finance
uh kind of promise if it comes to
fruition it will be
incredibly valuable right i think i
think there's a lot of people um
who would have a hard time arguing
against that one of the core components
of it
is oracles which is something that you
have been working on for a while
talk to us about kind of the importance
of oracle's to that infrastructure
and then maybe after we go over that we
can get into some real world examples
but just
what what is the oracle kind of
importance in this infrastructure and
how do you see that evolving over time
sure so there's there's a few different
um
categories of what of what an oracle
does um at the simplest level
what an oracle will be already does
successfully
in in in the d5 landscape is provide
data
so smart contracts exist in in these
blockchain-based
blockchain based kind of platforms
that are purposefully walled off from
the rest of the world for security
reasons
and that security is what makes the
smart contract reliable right so you you
want
um a hyper secure hyper-reliable
form of digital agreement and in order
to do that
you've made a system of minors and a
collection of individual
civil resistant nodes that basically
come to consensus come to agreement
about a smart contract and
and its current state and its and its
changes in state
right and what oracles do is
they enable data to flow into that into
that environment
because that environment is purposefully
and will continue to be
limited in its capacity to interact with
something called an api
or a data feed or basically any external
system
and this is the sense in which a
blockchain only knows what's in a
blockchain itself
and and usually what that is is the
signatures from private keys
and token movements and because that's
the functionality of blockchains
generally speaking
that's what um that's what they've been
used for so far right so what oracles do
is they expand the universe of what
smart blockchains and smart contracts
can be used for
by providing data then the question kind
of becomes you know what are the
categories of data
two categories of data that that i find
to be quite quite useful and important
are price and data that enables
insurance products so basically price
data
enables lending protocols to generate
that yield that i was talking about
because you could you can properly value
assets and you can return yield on those
assets
you also need price data to make
derivatives markets which which generate
their own type of exposure and yield and
all kinds of kind of
various types of returns and then
another example would be weather data so
what weather data does is it provides
data about rainfall and temperature and
it
allows the creation of something like
crop insurance so for example one of our
users arbol they generate
um crop insurance and they do that in
the us
but also very importantly in countries
like costa rica cambodia
and other countries where they aren't
able to have insurance
because their local legal system doesn't
enable that and all the insurance that's
generated by something
like our goal in the us or in these
emerging markets where there's literally
going from zero to one with having
insurance
provides uh revenues and collateral
into the blockchain format into the
crypto format
so so basically what what oracle's do
initially is they provide a lot of data
which allows people to make financial
products that
accrues greater and greater amounts of
value into the smart contract format
in in various other types of contracts
that were previously not in existence on
a blockchain
lending derivatives insurance products
and as this value in the smart contract
on chain format grows and grows and
grows
it actually begins a virtuous cycle
because as you get insurance premiums
you can turn those into securities or
tokens or whatever you want to turn them
into
and and and and feed those into a defy
market
that then converts those into into yield
and creates more of an incentive to
create more insurance products
right so initially oracles generate
the data rich environment in which
financial products
need to be made without a data-rich
environment you don't you don't really
have financial
products being made then you have some
additional uses of oracles one
one of them is the ability to do
computations
that blockchains and smart contracts
can't or don't do
for scalability or or complexity reasons
one of those examples is something like
randomness
so now in our system we have something
called chain link vrf it took us
you know well over a year close to two
years to put it together we got it
audited by
by some top auditors and it's actually a
novel form of generating
on-chain verifiable randomness so we can
prove that
there's a source of randomness that is
ungamable
by the creator of the application or the
user of the application
and this is very important for
generating gaming
generating things like fair token sales
and and any
number of other of other use cases that
once again bring great
you know generating nfts non-fungible
tokens that then become their own assets
and this is another example of where an
oracle generates an input
into the smart contract system which
enables
more value to be put onto that system
and then the nfts for example that might
be generated by
a randomness outcome because people know
they're generated fairly
and that nobody is gaming the system to
generate nfts as a way to steal from
other users
to generate the good enfts for
themselves those nfts
those non-fungible tokens those kind of
digital goods digital assets
become more valuable and then they also
flow into the d5 ecosystem
right the the third and and final
example that i think is is relevant to
the point
earlier about bitcoin is is something
called proof of reserve
so for for wrapped bitcoin and and soon
for other assets
what what an oracle network is able to
do it's able to prove
that an asset is actually somewhere
and it's actually in a certain state so
for the key for
for wrapped bitcoin with our proof of
reserve approach does
is prove that there is actually bitcoin
locked up within the bitcoin chain
for every wbtc that's in existence
somewhere else
and that creates a greater level of
assurance that the wbtc
is true truly about a real bitcoin and
increases its
adoption in various d5 program
protocols and various kind of products
as a form of collateral right so what an
oracle network does there is create
various assurances
that the collateral or the asset
in a d5 protocol can be relied upon and
that gives it
an ability to get even better yield
we've since then expanded that
to to one stable coin where you can
actually prove that the stable coin is
backed by
a real bank account and the oracle
network
checks if the money is in the bank
account um i think an hourly or a daily
basis but it checks it it checks it very
regularly and it's like an ongoing
technological audit of the value in that
bank account
shifting us from a world where we would
have to wait for a six every six month
or annual audit of that stable coin
right and and so what i what i think
oracle networks do is they both create a
data rich environment
where as we put more and more data on
chain about new commodities
new new various markets we see various
decentralized financial products popping
up around those
those those markets right it also
provides a large
um a large amount of surety
about how some of these protocols work
whether they're relying on bitcoin in
the form of rap bitcoin
or whether they're generating something
like a non-fungible token that's then
used as an asset
in other protocols as a form of
collateral the ability for oracle's to
prove
that a certain collateral has a certain
value
is is actually in my opinion something
that would have would have seriously
softened and possibly stopped the 2008
financial crisis
because if you had oracles proving the
value of homes or the how many homes a
certain
mortgage holder had and returning that
data into a transparent
financial system then the boom and bust
cycle of the 2008 financial crisis
wouldn't have been nearly as large
and so or oracles basically provide both
data
and um assurances that
the value within defy
is is actually there yeah talk a little
bit about what needs to happen
for oracle's and d5 to go more
mainstream
how do we get more people using this
stuff is it user experience
is there a macro environment uh kind of
change that needs to occur
what gets defined oracles more
mainstream
uh i think there's two kinds of uh
patterns that that that are going to
emerge and they're probably
probably both gonna gonna emerge they're
they're both slowly already emerging the
the slow case
is what we see right now in the
community right we see 450 billion
in the crypto format we see anywhere
between 10 to 15 billion
in the d5 format and we see more uh from
the crypto format flowing into d5
and and we see a number of protocols in
a number of teams becoming successful
and successful enough to stand on their
own two feet for many years
to get financing and to continue to
exist as
as teams that make d5 protocols right so
you you basically have an ecosystem
that has enough capital within it so
that people can make financial products
become successful other people can see
their success
make even better and even more financial
products and continue this cycle
of better and better financial products
in an ecosystem with sufficient usership
and sufficient value
to to continually um make that
worthwhile
right so there's there's a larger enough
of a market so that the financial
products in d5
even without any additional value coming
into the ecosystem
is large enough and is compelling enough
to
have really high quality defy teams you
know like synthetics and ave and yearn
and others
building better and better financial
products and doing that at kind of a
breakneck pace
and i think what that will lead to is
better and better financial products on
chain
more and more usable financial products
unchained and
and and actually more accessibility to
those right and and i think one of the
other drivers of that is yield
the ability for these financial products
to generate anywhere from one to eight
percent
yield versus that half percent or less
yield that you get from the
existing financial system is going to be
a very attractive
property if it continues and so people
are are slowly going to realize
why am i why am i in the in the standard
financial system is if i get half a
percent
or less in yield whereas all i have to
do is turn my
my dollars or my yen or my pounds
into stable coins and then i suddenly
get two percent
or four percent and and all that all
that's going to really happen is the
rails to do that are just going to get
more and more polished
probably such that even robin hood or
various other
various other web interfaces that
already own users
end up using the protocols that are
being built today to do that
because at the end of the day those
applications seek to provide people
yield
they seek to provide returns they don't
really care where the returns come from
as long as they can get those returns
and as long as they can get them in a
reliable secure way
right so that's that's the slow case
the fast case is a kind of scary
scenario where the
global financial markets go through a
bust cycle right boom and bust cycles
are usually on a 8 to 12 timeline
and so on on the 8 to 12 timeline of of
global financial system boom and bust
cycles
we are very mu we we are very much kind
of on time and slightly overdue for that
part possibly because there's been a lot
of you know monetary policy and fiscal
stimulus and all kinds of different
stimulus
right possibly that's what's what's
what's kept the global financial market
going past what is likely to have
probably been a bust cycle if none of
this happened right
but invariably the nature of global
financial markets have
a massive boom and bus dimension that's
that's that's
unfortunately the nature of these
markets um you know there's debt cycles
around that there's all kinds of proof
that that's how it works
i think the reality that that that i
experienced in 2008 and that and that i
see
so unfold and it's proven by a lot of
the studies in a lot of the research and
a lot of the
kind of things that came out of the year
2009
after 2008 financial crisis is that
whereas people before while everything
was good
are completely insensitive to
counterparty risk and the transparency
of their relationship
with an institution right
when things go bad as they do in a bust
cycle
people go to the other side of the
spectrum they become hypersensitive
and and this is actually proven by the
places where you've seen these kind of
smaller bust cycles
for example a few years ago greece
locked up all of its atms and you can
only withdraw 66 euros
as an individual or an entity so whether
you had a business whether you're
individual you can only get 66 euros
and bitcoin wallet registration numbers
from greek ips
went up 300 percent
bitcoin wallet registration numbers from
other ips in neighboring countries that
were also worrying
about a similar type of debt situation
and their atms being locked up
those um countries saw equally large or
even larger 600
rises in bitcoin wallet address creation
from those ips
right so what you basically see is that
when the global financial system or
where the standard financial system
no longer provides people predictability
it no longer provides them safety it
never it no longer provides them yield
or
or what it's what it says it provides
right is is reliable access to your
assets
yield to combat inflation and like these
basic things
because you know bust cycles basically
lead to solvency issues
those solvency issues show people
that their relationship with
institutions is not what they thought
they were
once people see that their relationships
with institutions are not what they
thought they were
they seek alternatives the the
difference between 2008 and now
is that now bitcoin exists and and now
all these decentralized financial
products exist
and so and i think what's what the fast
case for d5 adoption is
is that when the next bust cycle comes
and the solvency
of financial institutions that people
have a relationship with and
the kind of relationship they have with
their assets in those into those
institutions
become proven to be much less reliable
and and much less um safe
than they thought this time when people
look around and say what are my
alternatives
blockchains will be front and center
saying we've been telling you
for a decade or more that this is going
to happen
and we've been building a system for a
decade or more
to combat exactly this problem
congratulations
it's it's it's ready it's come on we're
open we're open
come on in you can you can put your
value in a bitcoin
you can get yield on that value you can
have control on that without an
institution you know limiting you to
take out 66 euros per day
and right now when you say to somebody
you know what if the atms
only gave you back 66 euros per day
people go like oh you know i don't think
that's possible
i don't think that ever that can even
happen um but if that ever
did happen or a version of that even a
version of that ever happened
the hypersensitivity of people on on
that point
will uh in my in my in my in my internal
language
be called what i what i call the fast
case and and the fast case will be
my god i i have to it turns out my
relationship with my assets is
completely different than what i thought
how can i achieve holding of assets
places in places other than my mattress
while while still
um while still getting yield and while
still using technology
and and the only real answer will be
blockchains and bitcoins
and d5 um and so i think it's it's
actually good that that hasn't happened
yet and
and really that's going to be a very
painful thing so hopefully that doesn't
happen too much but the degree to which
it does happen
will create a very very sharp demand
and if if by that time d5 is
sufficiently polished which i really
think it already probably is
um then then you will see a very sharp
sharp adoption of it absolutely what are
you looking at
over the next 12 months maybe 24 months
uh what are the milestones that you're
paying attention to or the data points
that you're watching
um where you're like look this is either
going to signal that things are
drastically accelerating or decelerating
what are those milestones and data
points
uh i think total value locked in defy is
isn't is is an important milestone i
think the total amount of bitcoin
that is put into d5 products or put into
a format like wrapped bitcoin
that can be used in d5 products um
i do think the amount of new people
adopting bitcoin the amount of new
institutions
adopting crypto assets generally which
between paypal
um turning on kind of the ability for
for the average person to get
cryptocurrency
and all the different custody solutions
that i see
being generated in various uh in various
contexts by banks
and and the success that i think some
custody providers are going to have
because of that um which signals
basically institutional adoption right
the problem for institutions is
custody and the fact that good custody
providers are getting
financing rounds and gaining adoption
basically suggests that there's a lot of
institutions
gearing up to custody crypto assets
right
so i think it would be those three
things how much value is locked into the
decentralized financial product format
wherever that format kind of lives how
much of that value
how much value has flow flowed
from standard bitcoin into bitcoin
that's in a wrapped form or in some form
that can
be utilized trustlessly in a
decentralized financial product
and then also basically how many new um
new people are there how many new
institutions
like microstrategies and paypal and
others
have said um you know this crypto asset
thing
is is not fully understood by me
but i think it's good enough i think
it's close enough
that i should have some kind of
relationship to it
i should allow my users to consume it i
should own some bitcoin
in my treasury as an institution
you know these types of things right so
i think those would be the three things
that i would keep an eye on and if all
three of those
are are happening then i think the world
is is developing
very much in the in the direction of the
slow case
and when the fast case happens or if
whenever the fast case happens
i mean that'll be blatantly obvious
right that'll that'll be like a massive
explosion
uh it'll be it'll be a monumental shift
in people's thinking about
their relationship to assets and
financial products
because i think the reason actually
people don't make this shift yet
is many of them simply don't know that
this is an option
they simply don't know that they have
the option of a more reliable
better yield generating kind of more
secure financial product
as an option they just don't know that
and the reason they don't know that is
because there's there's no
there's not a sufficient force pushing
them to know that
you know they're kind of going through
their daily lives and they're used to
using the
the the products and the assets they
have and they're fine with that
and and that makes sense when
everything's good and everything is is
pretty stable and and the world is
predictable
but the point at which the world becomes
unpredictable um
is the point at which there are very
large technological shifts
that are able to bring predictability
back to the world
and in the financial kind of assets
landscape and in the financial products
landscape
and even in the insurance landscape that
that is what blockchains will provide
uh to what i think in the fast case
would be an increasingly unpredictable
world but but that that'll be
immediately apparent you won't need any
kind of idea
of like is that happening or not that'll
be happening very clearly
yeah i love your framework of kind of
the fast case and the slow case
um sergey listen i really really
appreciate the time this is fantastic
you guys have been doing a ton of work
um and you know i think i told you last
time that uh anytime the word oracle
comes up
immediately your name comes up uh and
the work you guys are doing
so uh that's a huge kudos to uh to all
that hard work
where can we send people to find out
more about what you're working on or
find you on the internet
sure sure we're at chain.link uh at
twitter it's twitter.com
chainlink we've actually been using that
pretty heavily to to let people know
about what's going on and
new users new new capabilities in the
chain link protocol and how it provides
data to all these systems
um i'm also on twitter at sergey nazarov
and i'm slowly slowly tweeting things
there uh
so so any any any of those three places
would be good
absolutely you've got no shortage of the
link marines that's for sure they are
all over twitter
uh listen sir thank you so much for uh
for your time and we will definitely
have to do this again in the future
my pleasure thank you for having me
you